mesures qui ont été prises lors d'un
conseil de défense sanitaire que le
président de la république a présidé
cette après midi en france comme en
europe la situation sanitaire et vous le
savez extrêmement tendu alors que la
cinquième vague porté par le variant dit
delta est loin d'être terminée même si
elle est moins puissante qu il y a
quelques semaines une nouvelle vague
déferle sur notre continent avec le
variant omicron sur lequel olivier et
veyran reviendra dans quelques instants
ce cumul s'est traduit le 24 décembre
dernier par le franchissement symbolique
de 100 mille cas de contamination
quotidien la tendance sur 7 jours
glissants est aujourd'hui à plus de 70
me le cas le taux d'accidents incidence
nationale est ainsi supérieur à 700 soit
au plus haut depuis le début de la crise
et nous déplorons 122
1677 décès dus au virus dans au dans nos
établissements de santé le niveau
d'hospitalisation continue sa
progression
certes un rythme modéré mais la
situation y demeurent particulièrement
tendu d'abord parce que nos soignants
sont épuisés ensuite parce que d'autre
pathologie affecte fortement le niveau
d'activité pour faire face à cette
situation la vaccination reste au coeur
de notre stratégie
comme dans celle des états voisins
j'entends bien autour de moi s'est levé
certaines interrogations je suis
régulièrement interrogé je ne comprends
pas monsieur le premier ministre je suis
vacciné j'ai même reçu les trois doses
et pourtant j'ai contracté le vario
micro alors la vaccination ne
serait-elle pas efficace la réponse est
claire si la vaccination n'empêche en
effet ni d'être contaminés ni de
transmettre la maladie d'abord elle
réduit ce risque d'être contaminé et ce
risque de transmettre la maladie mais
surtout surtout elle prémunit contre les
formes graves de l'aco vide et cela
reste vrai pour le variant omicron
surtout lorsque l'on à ces trois doses
ou deux doses plus la maladie donc oui
il est très clair que la vaccination
nous protège et que par voie de
conséquence elle protège les autres et
elle protège les services de santé
soumis à très rude épreuve là encore les
faits sont là dans tous les services de
soins critiques l'immense majorité des
personnes hospitalisées avec des formes
graves de l'aco vide ne sont pas
vaccinés ou n'ont pas de couverture
vaccinale complète j'ai parcourir la
france des services de réanimation pour
dire un rassemblement au personnel mon
soutien et mon admiration et je peux
vous dire qu'il n'ya pas photo sur la
nature des hospitalisations et des
formes graves ce sont des personnes non
vaccinées ou des malades vacciner mais
atteint de comorbidités graves
l'élément que les décisif est et demeure
la vaccination voilà pourquoi comme je
voulais dit lors de ma précédente
intervention nous faisons tout pour
accélérer et renforcer la vaccination
faire peser la contrainte sur les non
vaccinés tout en cherchant à aller vers
et à convaincre celles et ceux de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore très
éloignées du système de soins nous avons
ouvert sur la base du volontariat la
vaccination aux enfants de 5 à 11 ans en
priorisant ceux d'entre eux par ailleurs
atteint d'autres pathologies dès demain
matin suivante en cela la recommandation
de la haute autorité de santé il suffira
de trois mois après votre deuxième
injection ou votre première si vous avez
le coc vide pour pouvoir bénéficier de
votre rappel nous avons réalisé de
magnifiques performances collectives en
matière de vaccination en ce mois de
décembre
y compris avec une reprise salutaire est
indispensable des premières injections
il y a eu un ralentissement pendant
cette période de fêtes mais nous devons
absolument repartir de l'avant et je
veux à cet égard dire ma reconnaissance
et mes remerciements à toutes celles et
ceux qui sont fortement mobilisés pour
vacciner et aussi pour tester je pense
bien sûr aux professionnels de santé
tous confondus avec des pharmaciens
d'officine particulièrement sollicités
mais également au centre de vaccination
et à toutes celles et tous ceux qui en
assurent la gestion élus locaux et
notamment les maires personnels des
collectivités territoriales
sapeurs-pompiers grandes associations
caritatives et solidaire professionnels
de santé souvent retraités étudiants
bénévoles ils forment tous avec les
services de l'état préfets et agences
régionales de santé éducation nationale
santé au travail est désormais le
concours de militaires une formidable
chaîne de solidarité pour vous protéger
et répondre à ce défi qui est devant
nous à croître encore et encore la
vaccination première deuxième et
troisième dose dans les jours et
semaines à venir le conseil des
ministres d'aujourd'hui a dans le même
objectif adopter un projet de loi qui va
transformer le pass sanitaires on passe
vaccinale cela signifie que dans les
lieux où se passent s'applique depuis
plusieurs mois les restaurants les bars
les musées les théâtres les médiathèques
les séminaires et salons les salles de
sport les enceintes sportives et de
spectacles il faudra justifier d'être
vaccin mais pour pouvoir entrer la
production d'un test ne suffira plus
cette nouvelle règle si elle est votée
par le parlement
s'appliquera à compter du 15 janvier
prochain le projet de loi prévoit
également un accroissement des sanctions
contre les faux parce je veux vous dire
combien cette pratique me scandalise
comme premier ministre bien sûr mais
comme citoyen c'est beaucoup plus qu'un
contournement de la loi républicaine
déjà en soi très condamnable c'est un
acte délibéré de mise en danger d'autrui
aucune conviction personnelle ne saurait
le justifier ce n'est pas admissible et
nous devons collectivement nous donner
les moyens de l'enrayer et de le
sanctionner plus lourdement
au delà de nos efforts pour préserver et
renforcer notre bouclier
vaccinale contre le virus et ses
différents variant nous devons aussi
adapter nos mesures pour faire face aux
deux vagues liées à la fois au delta et
à omicron qui nous atteignent au même
moment et dans les effets et les risques
doivent être analysé au regard d'un
critère essentiel
les risque de formes graves et la
situation de nos hôpitaux comme olivier
vers en le développant dans un instant
ce que nous observons depuis trois
semaines environ en grande bretagne au
danemark
justifie à la fois prudence et vigilance
si l'on ne voit pas à ce stade de
surcharge hospitalière lié à omicron la
très forte contagiosité de ce variant la
vitesse à laquelle il se propage doivent
nous conduire au delà de la priorité
vaccinale à prolonger et amplifier de
manière proportionnée l'on mesure pour
freiner sa circulation soulager nos
services hospitaliers et éviter la
désorganisation de notre économie nous
sommes engagés dans une course contre la
montre dans le prolongement des
dispositions déjà prises notamment la
fermeture des discothèques nous avons
aujourd'hui adopter les mesures
complémentaires suivantes qui
s'appliqueront à compter de lundi
prochain pour une durée de trois
semaines pour freiner omicron les grands
rassemblements seront limités à une
jauge de 2000 personnes maximum à
l'intérieur et 5000 personnes maximum un
extérieur les concerts debout seront
interdit la consommation de boissons et
d'aliments sera interdite dans tous les
cinémas les théâtres les équipements
sportifs et les transports collectifs y
compris longue distance la consommation
dans les bars et cafés ne pourra plus se
faire seulement deux bouts mais
seulement de manière à 6 pour le
réveillon du 31 janvier je vous
renouvelle annie insistant les
recommandations que j'avais émise le 17
décembre dernier limitons les grandes
fêtes et les grands dîners portant le
masque à héron les pièces respectons les
gestes barrière testons nous toutes
mesures de bon sens qui font confiance à
notre sens des responsabilités
toutes les cérémonies de voeux prévue en
janvier seront par ailleurs annulés à
compter de la rentrée et pour une durée
de trois semaines le recours au
télétravail sera rendue obligatoire je
dis bien obligatoire dans toutes les
entreprises et pour tous les salariés
pour lequel il est possible à raison de
trois jours minimum par semaine et si
possible quatre jours quand cela est
possible
elisabeth bornes la ministre chargé du
travail mènera demain une concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux
par ailleurs l'obligation du masque déjà
partout applicable à l'intérieur sera
étendue et mieux respect et notamment
dans tous les centres villes les préfets
adopteront les dispositions
correspondantes en lien avec les maires
à ce stade notre volonté d'adapter nos
dispositifs de manière proportionnée
nous conduit à écarter toute mesure de
couvre feu nous referons le point à
l'occasion d'un prochain conseil de
défense convoqué le 5 janvier prochain
domaine s'agissant des établissements
d'enseignement nous resterons dans la
ligne que nous nous sommes fixés depuis
le début de la pandémie à savoir de ne
les ferme et qu'en dernier recours c'est
pour cette raison que nous ne
reporteront pas la rentrée ni ne
basculeront les collèges et les lycées
en distance yale de ce point de vue la
communication de ce jour des sociétés
savantes de pédiatrie est sans équivoque
et va totalement dans ce sens bien
entendu nous amplifierons à la rentrée
notre politique de surveillance et de
dépistage dans les établissements
scolaires au vu des données
épidémiologiques dans des conditions que
vous précisera olivier vers ans de même
les caractéristiques de mikron vont nous
conduire après avis des autorités
sanitaires à ajuster notre doctrine sur
la durée d'isolement
lorsque vous êtes positif ou lorsque
vous n'êtes qu'à contacter nous fixerons
ces règles nouvelles d'ici la fin de la
semaine une fois achevées les
consultations de nos instances
scientifiques
il s'agira à la fois d'adapter ses durée
en fonction du variant et là encore de
faire peser une contrainte moindre sur
les personnes vaccinées
les secteurs économiques impacté par les
décisions que la situation nous commande
de prendre seront indemnisés dans le
cadre de concertation qui rond sans
délai conduite par le ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire enfin des dispositions spécifiques
aux territoires d'outre-mer ont été
adoptés tout à l'heure par le conseil
des ministres concernant en particulier
l'île de la réunion où l'état d'urgence
sanitaire sera déclarée et la martinique
où il sera prolongé
mes chers concitoyens j'ai parfaitement
conscience de la situation qui est la
nôtre croyez bien que je la partage je
comprends que les mesures annoncées
que nous avons voulu comme toujours
proportionnée à la réalité de la
situation et à ses évolutions
prévisibles je comprends que ces mesures
puissent parfois suscité une forme de
ras-le-bol mais le président de la
république comme son gouvernement ne
cherche depuis le début de la crise qu à
vous protéger nous avons une stratégie
dont nous essayons de préserver la
cohérence tout en l'adaptant aux
évolutions de la pandémie priorité à la
vaccination en la complétant de mesures
adaptées et évolutives en fonction des
vagues et précisément des variants faire
peser le plus possible la contrainte sur
les non-vaccinés
maintenir autant que faire se peut les
écoles ouvertes dans l'intérêt même des
enfants et avec des protocoles
sanitaires adaptés assuré dans un cadre
protecteur l'exercice du travail et la
continuité de la vie de la nation tout
laisse tout cela semble un film qui n'en
finit pas pourtant quel changement avec
la situation d'il ya un an il y a un an
jour pour jour morissette était la
première française à se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui nous sommes grâce à la
mobilisation collective l'un des peuples
les plus vacciner au monde donc le mieux
protégé et bien nous devons poursuivre
en plis et ce mouvement pour faire face
à la nouvelle vague épidémique et le
futur texte de loi va nous y aider je
sais bien que nous devons poursuivre nos
efforts dans un combat qui peut parfois
sembler sens mais ce combat ensemble par
l'esprit de responsabilité et de
solidarité nous le gagnerons le
gagneront aussi un accroissant notre
attention aux pays les plus pauvres et
la france doit être fière d'être la
troisième nation au monde à donner des
doses de vaccin à ces pays restons
mobilisés
restons rassemblé restons déterminés
il n'ya pas d'autre voie pour faire face
et surmonter cette pandémie monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs nous faisons face
vous l'avais dit à deux vagues
simultanées qui sont liées à deux
variants différents et qui nécessitent
donc deux types de mesures différentes
mais complémentaires afin de les freiner
il ya d'abord le variant delta on le
connaît depuis plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois dans notre pays on en
connaît les caractéristiques la
dangerosité ce variant qui a envahi la
planète ou presque et qui continue de
sévir dans notre pays puisque après
avoir une stabilisation du nombre de cas
un pic qui a été atteint vers le début
le début du mois de décembre
si on constate dans certaines régions
une diminution des contaminations aux
variantes elle tape dans d'autres ils
continuent à augmenter et au global on
est sur une forme de plateau nous
n'avons donc pas terminé encore notre
combat contre ce variant delta mais
alors même que nous menons cette
bataille ce nouveau variant est art est
arrivé le variant omicron en provenance
d'afrique australe et c'est invariant
qui circule si vite qu'à l' inverse des
précédents variant nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de recul en provenance de
pays qui aurait été touché avant nous
pour maîtriser totalement les tenants et
aboutissants de ce variant on a
néanmoins quelques semaines par rapport
à l'afrique du sud une dizaine de jours
environ par rapport à l'anglais terre et
au danemark qui sont les pays les plus
touchés je le dis ce variant est en
train de traverser toute la planète
l'espagne l'italie qui avait été
relativement épargnée par le variante
lta connaissent aujourd'hui des pics
épidémiques en tout cas des montées
épidémie qui ne sont pas aux pics qui
dépasse tout ce qu'ils ont connu depuis
le début de la pandémie alors à l'heure
actuelle quels sont nos certitudes
concernant ce variant omicron d'abord on
sait qu mikron est beaucoup beaucoup
plus contagieux que les variants
précédent et notamment que le variant
delta au moins trois fois plus
contagieux le temps de doublement c'est
à dire le nombre de malades contaminés
double tous les deux jours s'étaient
tous les douze à quinze jours avec le
variant delta c'est pour ça que si vous
regardez la courbe si vous êtes attentif
on passe de dix mille à cent mille cas
par jour en l'espace de quelques jours
et tout laisse à penser que ça va
continuer à monter que nous pourrions
atteindre nous disent certains
modélisateurs plus de 250 mille cas par
jour d'ici au début du mois de janvier
ce qui est hors proportion par rapport à
ce que nous avons connu depuis le début
de la pandémie
deuxième constat mme omicron a cette
capacité rare contaminé des personnes
qui ont déjà attrapé le coc vide et même
des personnes qui ont eu des formes
symptomatiques voir des formes
symptomatiques sévère du coc vide cette
proportion a contaminé change aussi la
donne on peut donc retomber malade si on
attrape le omicron problèmes constants
au micro d est moins sensible aux
vaccins que le variant delta mais c'est
une bonne nouvelle la troisième dose
quand on est à jour de son rappel fait
immédiatement remonter le niveau de
protection au dessus de 90 % même bien
au-dessus de 90 % face au risque de
formes graves les personnes à risque
restent donc les personnes non vaccinées
les personnes vaccinées mais qui sont
très fragiles parce qu'elles sont très
âgés ou parce qu'elles souffrent
d'immunodépression et puis les personnes
qui ont un schéma vaccinal qui n'est pas
complet c'est-à-dire les personnes qui
ont eu deux doses mais pas encore leur
troisième c'est d'ailleurs le sens de l'
annonce que vous venez de faire et qui
reprend la proposition de la haute
autorité de santé de dire on n'attend
pas quatre ou cinq mois pour faire son
rappel des trois mois après la dernière
injection ou après la dernière
infections on peut recevoir cette
troisième dose une vaccination complète
éloigne le risque de formes graves
éloigne le risque de rennes passion même
si vous deviez contracté le virus
quatrième et dernier constat omicron
parce qu'il contamine vite et fort il
est responsable aujourd'hui de très
nombreux ce personne positive donc dont
certains malades mais également de très
nombreux cas contact et ça représente
donc un risque majeur d'absentéisme on
le voit déjà une hausse très forte et
des arrêts de travail ce qui peut avoir
un impact sur notre système de soins
quand ça touche les soignants on le
constate dans certains pays européens
mais ça peut aussi avoir un impact sur
l'activité de nos entreprises et de
façon générale sur la vie du pays si
nous avons des certitudes nous avons
encore des incertitudes
d'abord est il vrai que omicron est
moins dangereux c'est la question
centrale si omicron était aussi
dangereux que delta vu sa vitesse de
circulation on comprend qu'il mettrait
rapidement en péril tous les systèmes de
santé du monde en quelques jours mais
les études dont nous disposons en
provenance d'afrique du sud en
provenance du danemark en provenance du
royaume uni semble montrer que les
hospitalisations sont peu nombreuses et
pour des motifs moins graves à titre
d'exemple les besoin d'oxygène des
malades hospitalisés sont moins
importants et les durée moyenne
d'hospitalisation sont plus courts ce
qui est évidemment une très bonne
nouvelle si elle devait se confirmer si
elle devait se confirmer parce qu'il y
encore des billets dans ses études
notamment le variant au bik ron
actuellement dans ces pays touche
contamine surtout des percées des
personnes qui sont jeunes c'est aussi
d'ailleurs le cas en france et on sait
que les gens jeunes ont moins souvent
l'hôpital or on sait qu inévitablement
quand les jeunes sont touchés par le
virus au bout d'un moment ce sont des
personnes moins jeunes qui finissent par
être touchée et donc mon message
vraiment destiné aux personnes fragiles
ou parce qu'elles sont malades ou parce
qu'elles sont âgés surtout si vous êtes
en attente de votre troisième dose de
vaccin faites attention à vous limitez
vos déplacements prenez garde face à ce
variant pour lequel on a encore cette
part d'inconnu plus grande vigilance
donc comme annoncé par le premier
ministre et tenant compte des avis des
autorités sanitaires nous rabaissons le
délai je le disais à trois mois ce qui
veut dire que désormais ce sont plus de
45 millions de nos concitoyens qui sont
concernés par le rappel la moitié a déjà
reçu ce rappel 22 millions et demi ce
soir donc nous allons y arriver ensemble
grâce à la mobilisation extraordinaire
des centres et des libéraux
deuxième incertitude est ce que omicron
va entraîner une vague épidémique
explosive mais brève pourquoi je pose
cette question parce qu on observe en
afrique du sud après une montée très
forte du nombre de cas une diminution
rapide et aussi importante du nombre de
contaminations mais attention parce que
dans ce pays d'abord ce sont les
vacances estivales et donc ça peut
changer la donne en terme de
contamination et c'est également un pays
qui a été fortement touchée par les
variants précédent avec un niveau
d'immunité collectif plus fort mais
enfin bon on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
bonne nouvelle est évidemment nous
souhaitons ardemment que cette vague
soit la plus courte possible
autre incertitude est ce que omicron
peut être freiné par des mesures
totalement classiques tels que nous
avons pu en mettre en place dans notre
pays a priori le danemark qui est mis en
place un certain nombre de mesures n'a
pas constaté d'effet de freinage sur la
dynamique épidémique parce que mikron
est tellement contagieux qu'hormis
finalement un confinement généralisée
rien ne semble capable d'en freiner la
course en tout cas aucun pays à date n'a
pu totalement le freiner dans sa
dynamique de croissance épidémique en
revanche et c'est le sens des annonces
qui ont été faites par le premier
ministre on constate qu'ils nous avons
tout intérêt à limiter les grands
rassemblements pourquoi parce que dans
les grands rassemblements il y à des
risques que quelqu'un puisse entraîner
la contamination d'un maximum de
personnes autour de lui et que cela a un
effet qui accentue la dynamique de
l'épidémie et donc c'est pour ça que
nous voulons mettre fin par exemple aux
situations qui permettait vous le voyez
quand vous sortez de retirer son masque
et le temps de boire ou le temps de
manger comme par exemple quand on est au
cinéma c'est pour ce que c'est pourquoi
désormais le port du masque sera
obligatoire toute la durée de la séance
ce sera le cas dans cet établissement
recevant du public et c'est pourquoi
aussi il ya des limitations du nombre de
personnes dans les grains des notes dans
les grands rassemblements qui vient
d'être décidées et annoncées par le
premier ministre pour les trois
prochaines semaines
dernière incertitude escaut micron va
freiner la vague delta qui est toujours
en circulation dans notre pays et dont
l'impact sanitaire continue d'augmenter
ou est-ce qu'il va créer ce que j'avais
appelé un phénomène de lame de fond
c'était une forme de mega vague
constituée des deux vagues qui chemine
chacun de leur côté je les dis pour
rouleurs si delta a cessé d'augmenter
dans notre pays il se maintient à un
niveau élevé en plateau dans certaines
régions il continue même d'augmenter et
c'est ce qui justifie notamment
l'obligation de télétravail que vous
venez d'annoncer monsieur le premier
ministre parce que le télétravail est
très efficace sur un variant qui est
moins contagieux que le variant mikron
comme le variant delta c'est pour ça
c'est vraiment le rationnel de
combinaison des différentes mesures pour
arriver à freiner les faits des deux
vagues qui se cumulent je le rappelle
parmi les risques que nous identifions
il ya l'impact sur la société d'une
multiplication des contaminations et des
cas contact qui peut entraîner une
paralysie des services publics et privés
à l'instar de nombreux voisins et compte
tenu des caractéristiques propres aux
variants omicron nous avons saisi le
haut conseil de santé publique qui
émettra des recommandations cette fin de
semaine probablement d'ailleurs le 31
décembre en vue d'alléger les conditions
d'isolement des cas contactez dernier
point monsieur le premier ministre une
question qui revient beaucoup et qui est
profondément légitime qui concerne les
enfants vous en avait parlé oui le virus
circule chez les enfants il circule à
l'école ils circulent à la maison c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs un protocole
scolaires sanitaires a été élaboré c'est
pourquoi il est révisé régulièrement en
fonction de l'état de circulation du
virus est en fonction de l'état des
connaissances scientifiques
oui nous assumons de sanctuariser
l'éducation des enfants un enfant qui ne
va pas à l'école est un enfant qui peut
rencontrer de graves difficultés et là
c'est le ministre en charge des
solidarités qui parle et c'est
d'ailleurs également compliqué vous le
savez quand vous l'avez vécu à la maison
oui il arrive que les enfants dans de
rares situations et surtout lorsqu'ils
souffrent par ailleurs déjà de maladies
sous jacentes puisse développer des
formes graves à date 190 enfants sont
hospitalisés en france pour qu'ovide 35
enfants sont même en service de
réanimation c'est vrai et c'est pour
cette raison notamment que nous avons
ouvert la vaccination aux enfants âgés
de 5 à 11 ans la semaine dernière et je
vous donnais une comparaison chaque
année la bronchiolite entraîne
l'hospitalisation de 23 mille enfants 23
mille enfants en comparaison aux
chiffres que j'ai donné ses quatorze
mille enfants qui sont admis à l'hôpital
chaque année en raison de la fameuse
gastro entérite est actuellement il ya
plus d'enfants hospitalisés en
réanimation pédiatrique en raison d'une
bronchiolite qu'en raison d'une forme
grave du coc vide chaque année c'est en
moyenne deux à trois mille enfants qui
vont en réanimation pour cause de
bronchiolite et pour autant la vie est
importante dans les crèches auprès des
assistantes maternelles dans les petits
niveaux scolaires elle ne s'arrête pas à
chaque fois que l'épidémie redémarre
mais néanmoins c'est pourquoi nous
mettons en place des mesures encore une
fois de protection une bonne décision de
santé publique c'est une décision
médicale mais c'est aussi une décision
sociétale évidemment si de nouvelles
données devaient apparaître en france ou
à l'étranger sur l'impact du variant
omicron chez les enfants nous pourrions
être amenés à prendre toute mesure utile
pour les protéger et dans l'intervalle
nous continuons à travailler avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale pour
renforcer les mesures qui sont
susceptibles de réduire les risques
notamment la question de l'aération de
l'équipement des classes qui ne sont pas
encore en capteur de co2 pour vous dire
quand il est temps d'ouvrir les fenêtres
et la porte mais également le système de
test itératif et de dépistage
systématique par test salivaire
notamment qui a été mis en place depuis
plusieurs mois désormais dans notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre dont
nous allons prendre quelques questions
si vous le voulez bien
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur miss de la santé mathieu coatch
bfm tv le conseil scientifique a fait
part de son inquiétude sur une possible
des organisations de la société à la
rentrée à cause des arrêts maladies qui
sont très nombreux considérez vous que
ces mesures celles que vous venez
d'annoncer vont empêcher cette
désorganisation et une possible
paralysie de l'économie puis j'ai une
deuxième question vous avez fait
référence au faux-pas sanitaire qui
circulent que prévoyez vous concrètement
pour empêcher leur circulation est ce
que l'ajout d'une photo par exemple sur
les pass est envisagée ou bien une
vérification d'identité systématiques à
l'entrée des lieux où ils sont
obligatoires je vous remercie bon
peut-être de deux trois questions à la
suite si vous voulez bien
marie lecomte france info vous annoncez
ramener le délai pour la vacciner pour
la troisième dose à trois mois les plus
de 65 ans peuvent se faire vacciner de
cette troisième dose depuis début
septembre est ce que ça veut dire que
d'ores et déjà ils peuvent prendre
rendez vous pour leur quatrième dose en
doutait
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur le
préfet ministre bonjour monsieur meunier
de la santé thomas des prix rtl que
quelle mesure prenez vous pour les
meetings politiques
est-ce que les jauges concerne également
les meetings de la campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui on le sait le
pass sanitaires n'étaient pas exigée
pour ses meetings
s'arrête là pour ce premier jeu commence
il voulait bien par la dernière question
pardon mais juste pour vous rappelez
vous rappelez pardon pour rappeler à
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent que
l'exercice du culte d'une part et les
activités politiques et électorales
d'autre part sont soumises à des
dispositions spécifiques dans notre
droit constitutionnel qui le rassure on
va dire une protection encore plus forte
donc il est clair que les mesures pour
répondre à votre question que j'ai
annoncée ce soir ne concerne pas les
meetings politiques compte tenu de cette
spécificité par ailleurs pour préparer à
dire la campagne électorale plus de
manière plus générale parce qu à pas
cher monsieur que la question des
réunions publiques que vous venez
d'évoquer le ministre de l'intérieur en
se rapprochant évidemment du conseil
constitutionnel qui je vous rappelle un
rôle majeur notamment dans
l'organisation des élections
présidentielles
réunira sans doute une commission un peu
comme nous l'avions fait pour les
élections régionales en associant toutes
les formations politiques pour nous
accorder on va dire sur des règles qui
soient évidemment protectrice par
rapport à la situation sanitaire mais
qui tiennent compte de la spécificité
de cette activité fondamentale c'est à
dire finalement de l'exercice de la
démocratie qu avant de passer la parole
à olivier un qu'olivier ferrand
effectivement par rapport à la première
question relative à la désorganisation
de l'économie à la haie à l'un des
derniers avis rendu à ce sujet par le
par le conseil scientifique c'est tout
l'enjeu me semble-t-il de la non ce que
nous avons fait avec le ministre des
solidarités de la santé de l'adaptation
de la notion le cas positifs et surtout
de qu'à contacter si vous relisez en
particulier l'avis en question
aux variants au micro tout se tient
c'est à dire que effectivement s'il
présente des formes moins graves tout en
étant beaucoup plus contagieux il faut
que les autorités sanitaires j'insiste
bien auprès de vous nous fasse des
propositions nous les avons saisis comme
l'indiqué olivier verrons nous
disposerons tous à vendredi normalement
le 31 c'est ça et à l'issue de
l'ensemble de ces propositions nous vous
annoncerons les dispositions concrètes
que nous retiendrons pour effectivement
nous nous prémunir le plus possible de
cette désorganisation potentielles liées
comme vous l'avez bien compris à la
contagiosité est très forte de ce
variant sur le ministre sur les autres
questions sur les autres questions y
avait une question sur les contrôles du
faux-pas sanitaires dont c'est vrai que
le texte le projet de loi gouvernemental
et le débat parlementaire devrait
aborder la question du contrôle
d'identité
pour limiter le recours est l'impact
néfaste de de ses faux-pas sanitaire ce
sera un point de discussion important il
avait déjà été discutée dans un
précédent texte de loi n'y avait pas eu
de majorité qui s'étaient fait jour au
parlement je pense que la situation a
changé et de la même manière j'entends
que des parlementaires des groupes
d'opposition qui jusqu'ici ont voté
contre le past and i terres 10
que désormais ils sont prêts à
accompagner la transformation de ce pas
cela était en passe vaccinale signe
qu'on apprend tout ce qu'on évolue tous
et je le redis est sans aucune ambiguïté
si on arrive à voir des consensus dans
le débat parlementaire ce sera forcément
oui juste pour préciser ce que prévoit
après l'avis du conseil d'état parce
qu'un point très sensible
le texte qui a été délibéré cet après
midi on conseillera sur la question
précise que vous soulevez d'abord que
les forces de l'ordre
pourront accéder aux erp et pour
procéder à ces contrôles parce qu'il y
avait eu des manques de clarté des
textes en vigueur et donc des
jurisprudences divergentes et surtout
que les exploitants de rp auront la
possibilité en cas de doute avéré de
vérifier eux-mêmes les entités je sais
que c'est un sujet difficile pour lequel
je vais très claires dans ma réponse
nous allons surtout mobilisé les forces
de sécurité intérieures mais mais je
crois que c'était votre question le
texte de loi fera effectivement il
avancé en ce sens attends de voir
attendant de voir comme l'a dit le
ministre ce que donneront les débats
parlementaires pardon olivier
l'autre question qui portait c'était sur
la quatrième dose de vaccination c'est
une possibilité
d'ailleurs on voit remonter des demandes
qui émanent de personnes fragiles parce
qu'elles sont âgés ou parce qu'elles
sont malades qui ont reçu leur troisième
dose en septembre et qui s'inquiète de
savoir si elles doivent à nouveau
réactualiser leur vaccination pour
pouvoir être protégés dans la durée
contre le vario mikron il faut qu'on
puisse leur apporter une réponse je n'ai
pas la réponse à vous apporter
aujourd'hui on travaille au niveau
international avec les homologues
européens avec israël pourquoi israël
parce que ils ont commencé la campagne
de rappel plutôt que le reste de la
planète et donc ils sont capables de
nous dire avant les autres si le niveau
d'immunité faire la capacité à combattre
le virus que confère la troisième dose
de vaccin diminue avec le temps comme
c'était le cas pour le deuxième
injection et s'il convient de faire une
quatrième élection donc j'ai pas la
réponse formelle à vous donner je vous
dis juste qu'on est totalement ouvert à
cette perspective est que le plus
simplement du monde en transparence et
le plus naturellement du monde s'il faut
aller devant les français pour leur dire
qu'une nouvelle dose de vaccination est
nécessaire pour protéger les plus
fragiles nous le ferons parce que je
considère que la vaccination est une
chance je comprends que ça puisse être
embêtant de prendre rendez-vous d'aller
se faire vacciner qui s'appuie soulevé
des inquiétudes mais je suis en ce
moment beaucoup plus ceci par des gens
qui sont plus inquiets à l'idée de ne
plus être suffisamment protégé donc
cette question viendra en son temps pas
maintenant
observé d'ailleurs comme moi je pense
c'est des observateurs attentifs que le
gouvernement israélien qui est
effectivement pour toutes les raisons
qu'a indiqué monsieur véran bonne avance
puisque la troisième dose a été
administré un peu avant les autres pays
avaient commencé par faire une annonce
en disant on va faire la 4e et puis à 10
pour l'instant je sur soit ma décision
donc en fait je pense qu'il faut comme
toujours un que quand on observe les
effets de la troisième dans la durée est
ce que ces effets sont longs et
évite une quatrième si au contraire nous
avons médicalement des indices disant
que ce n'est pas le cas évidemment je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de doute sur le
fait que nous ouvrirons cette quatrième
dose afin la possibilité de
l'administrer mais encore une fois on
n'a pas le recul sur la durée de
l'efficacité on sait que c'est très
excité assez quand on est vaccinés ont
fait que l'efficacité maximale une fois
qu'on a eu une injection de rappel et
qu'ensuite elle peut décliner avec le
temps on verra ce qu'il en est pour la
troisième dose voilà
allez un autre petit jeu de questions
vient d'annoncer le premier concert
monsieur le ministre une question pour
ces news concernant la vaccination à des
personnalités et des personnes les plus
âgées notamment les 80 ans et plus c'est
la population la plus fragile elle la
tranche d'âge la moins vacciner est ce
que vous prévoyez des mesures pour aller
encore plus vers cette personne ces
personnes potentiellement isolés comme
le porte à porte comme le font à nos
voisins britanniques par exemple
la porte on en fait depuis des mois pas
des semaines des mois les crs dans les
collectivités appel on les fichiers des
personnes qui sont fragiles de par leur
âge puisque chaque année les appels
l'été quand la canicule les maires les
appelle les médecins généralistes sont
les fichiers de tous ces patients et les
appels était de les convaincre les
infirmiers à domicile font beaucoup
d'obstination de personnes âgées isolées
les familles les amis tout l'entourage
il y à un nombre de personnes quelques
centaines de milliers alors il et on ne
l'estiment pas aux chiffres près mais il
ya encore des personnes qui sont âgés et
qui refusent le dax 1 je ne crois pas qu
à ce stade ce soit quelqu'un qui ne soit
pas informé et je redis que depuis plus
de six mois désormais nous en voyons si
besoin une ambulance à la maison
gratuitement chercher la personne pour
la vacciner à la maison et c'est tout
les effecteurs sont disponibles on
continue d'avancer et de progresser mais
il ya encore des gens savent c'est
parfois des gens qui sont centenaires et
qui vous dit deux mois m'embêter avec
votre truc c'est vraiment le genre de
situation qui sont rencontrés par contre
pour les primo vaccination les gens qui
jusqu'ici il voulait passer à vacciner
ce qu'ils aient j'attends le vaccin
français où on n'a pas de recul ou je
risque rien eux sont de plus en plus
nombreux à venir se faire vacciner près
de 35000 un jour comme aujourd'hui on a
eu un pic à 50 milles sur une journée la
semaine dernière on a fait 200 milles
primo vaccination sur une semaine ce qui
est bien ça veut dire qu'on va regagner
on va gagner progressivement les 53
millions de français qui ont reçu une
injection on est parmi vraiment les
videurs je pense qu'on est sur le podium
européen voire mondial en termes de
couverture vaccinale si on arrive à
convaincre tout le monde sait qu'on aura
bien fait notre travail si vous me
permettez que c'est une question majeure
tiens c'est à dire que parler de la 3e
et de la 4e doors éventuel la troisième
dose c'est très important ne doit pas
nous faire oublier la première bon il ya
encore même si nous avons sont parmi les
pays du monde on a franchi le fameux
seuil de 91 % de la population éligible
primo vaccinées en france et c'est
remarquable et ya encore des gens qu'ils
ne sont pas ça fait plusieurs centaines
de milliers voire plusieurs millions de
l'an et en particulier la signora vous
êtes parfaitement raisonnable ce sont
les plus vulnérables et comme vous dites
des personnes de plus de 80 ans présente
assurément une exposition et une
vulnérabilité plus grande au virus donc
il faut aller les ché et
je voudrais insister dans ce cas dit
olivier rend une disposition que nous
avons pris enfin que la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie a négocié avec les
syndicats infirmiers
c'est la vaccination à domicile de ces
personnes par des personnes qui les
connaissent bien et qu'ils vont les voir
pour d'autres motifs évidemment que
celui là et qui sont les infirmières
libérales à domicile bon comme nous
avons fortement après négociation la
cnam a revalorisé
l'acte vaccinal à domicile fait par les
infirmières libérales est entré en
vigueur il ya peu de jours nous en
attendons évidemment beaucoup puisque en
fait on l'a revalorisé c'est pas une
question tellement pécuniaire mes chats
peuvent chacun peut comprendre que
vacciner quelqu'un il faut le convaincre
il faut attendre les fameuses 15 minutes
qui peuvent être vain j'ai une personne
âgée pour ci a pas d'effets secondaires
est là donc ça prend du temps
l'infirmière n'a pas forcément beaucoup
parce que là énormément de travail donc
on attend beaucoup de cette mesure et
j'observe avec satisfaction à la suite
du ministre que plus globalement le la
simple annonce de l'arrivée fait de la
transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale a effectivement conduit
un certain nombre et je les en félicite
de nos concitoyens vers la vaccination
avec des des taux qui sont pas encore
suffisants à mes yeux ma fait qu'ils
notent encore aujourd'hui même année
c'est un retour et surtout qui nous
rappelle je pars demain de faire cette
réponse longue mais c'est important que
la primovaccination reste la mère de nos
priorités parce que comme dirait l'autre
c'est difficile d'avoir sa troisième
dose si on n'a pas eu sa première
donnée point un complément pendant cette
réponse ne croyez pas qu'il y as en
réanimation des gens qui ont 80 90 ans
vacciné un parce que j'entends le
discours qui consiste à dire il
suffirait pas chine et les personnes
fragiles qui ne sont pas encore et de ne
pas demander aux autres de se raffiner
factuellement c'est faux factuellement
si vous allez dans un service de
réanimation vous allez voir aussi des
gens qui ont 40 50 ans j'étais la
semaine dernière on s'y rend
régulièrement avec le premier ministre
et je me permets c'est pour ça que je
reprenais la parole pour les
pour les femmes enceintes on a un sujet
avec des femmes en simple qui parfois ne
se font pas vacciner parce qu'elles ont
peur pour leur petit ou parce que
parfois elles sont mal conseillé mal
orienté jeu refait passer le message est
promis aux équipes de réanimation de le
faire passer les équipes à paris ou
ailleurs qui ont des femmes enceintes
qui ont fait des copies de graves
parfois avec des conséquences pour le
cdh suisse pour le nourrisson et pour la
mère ce sont des situations de vie
absolument terrible pour des soignants
même les plus expérimentés et surtout
pour les familles concernées donc
vraiment le message n'hésitez pas à vous
faire vacciner si vous êtes enceinte
c'est plus que possible c'est recommandé
très bien merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs